all right so
let's go ahead and get started uh it's
my pleasure to introduce prasada
govendra
who's here at berkeley and he's going to
tell us about algorithms and barriers of
interactability and high-dimensional
statistical inference
hello thanks
thanks for the invitation um
uh it's a pleasure to
speak uh at an event in person after
such a long time um
uh it's even much bigger pleasure to
talk about something it's really close
to my heart right now
um so
uh today and two lectures today and two
lectures tomorrow
i'll try to talk about a few things that
go between algorithms
and also barriers
in high dimensional statistical
inference
it's very broad term high dimensional
statistical inference so let's see what
i really mean what class of problems i'm
talking about
so
okay so here's a problem
i
take n vertices
and i pick a random coloring of these n
vertices
into k colors okay and after i color
them with into k colors
i
uh add edges between them in particular
for every pair uv which have different
colors
i include the edge between u and v
with probability d over n
and
so it's a it's a erdogan graph
conditioned on
being colorable
being this being a coloring
and
then
you know you erase all the colors
and you get this graph
and the goal
uh
is to
given the graph recover the coloring
even partially can we recover anything
about the original coloring that created
this graph
and that would be the recovery problem
and a weaker goal would be a detection
problem where you want to distinguish
uh this graph from a random erdostiny
graph of the same average degree
okay so that's a planted coloring
problem
here's another variant of the same
problem
so here what you have is
uh you have
uh your vertices divided into two blocks
uniformly at random
and
[Music]
for every pair you v
you add an edge
between u and v
with probability
which is
d over n
times 1 plus epsilon if they are between
the two sides so these are the two sides
and
b over n times 1 minus epsilon if they
are on the same side
and the goal is given this graph can we
recover the coloring even partially
okay and for more importantly for what
values of the degree d and the epsilon
can we recover this
all right so this is a
quite a fascinating problem in that
there's a lot of very interesting work
that has been done on this problem
in particular this is the landscape of
what happens to this problem as you vary
the parameters
so let's fix the degree d
and let's just increase the epsilon so
as you increase the epsilon you're
actually
increasing the proportion of edges that
cross the partition
and you're decreasing the proportion of
edges that are inside the partition
the graph looks more and more like a
bipartite graph as you increase epsilon
so at some point
you actually hope that you can recover
the partition and in fact
this is very
strict transition that happens
at this threshold called the question
stigm threshold which corresponds to
degree which is one over epsilon squared
exactly d
d is equal to one over epsilon squared
exactly beyond that degree
this
there are efficient algorithms that can
partially recover the coloring that you
started with
and just below that
it's information theoretically
impossible to recover calories
i should say that
your x-axis compared to my x-axis is the
opposite like the problem becomes with
you like easier as you move to the right
right
yes so my x-axis is
usually like the signal
it so as you move to the right the
signal strength becomes larger and
efficient algorithms have exist to the
right
as you know
right so partial recovery just means
that you find some assignment um x which
uh whose
uh correlation with the original
coloring is half plus delta for some
delta v sixty percent correlated with
the original actually it may be the same
because it's like the planted version
right since it is the same
questions are good because uh i'm
actually having difficulty speaking with
this mask on
so it helps me take a breath okay so
all right and in fact there's a very
beautiful algorithm it's based on
non-backtracking what matrix we'll get
to all of this later
so in so if you go back to
k communities which is a planted k
coloring problem
there are the the
issue becomes even more interesting
because now there are two thresholds
there is a threshold beyond which it's
information theoretically possible
to detect for instance that the graph is
not random
and
there is another threshold beyond which
efficient algorithms exist
and then there is this middle region
where it's information theoretically
possible
so if you spend exponential amount of
time you can recover the coloring
but
it's conjectured to be computationally
hard
so that's the landscape k communities
and you know
for instance if you look at the planted
k coloring problem
uh this conjecture transition from
easiness to hardness says that if and if
the degree of the graph is at least k
minus 1 whole square
so if k is 5 if the degree is 16
at degree 16 the problem becomes
easy and a degree less than 16 the
problem is hard
so it's quite sharp transition and a
quite quite a precise prediction of when
the problem gets easier hard and for me
actually this is one of the
simplest average case problems
that is actually has
is meant to be hard
just planted k coloring
um and it has a very predictable
transition too
okay so this is these we're talking
about graphs so far
next let you know there are related
class
csps so i'll give you an example here so
planted not all equal sat
so what's the situation here
we have n variables x 1 through x n
when variables which are boolean
variables
and there's an assignment to these
variables which i've drawn here
and for every triple
i j k
if
uh
i a x i x j x k are not equal
then you add a clause with some
probability
if they're equal if they're all equal
they add a clause with a different
probability
in particular uh you know if you
if you look at planted not all equal set
which is fully satisfiable you add
clauses only
when
the
three variables are not equal
but this is a mixture where you add
clauses with probably a higher
probability if they are not equal and a
lower protein they are equal
okay
so you have a
constraint satisfaction problem instance
after this where i give you the clauses
of course you won't see the assignment
and your goal is can you recover the
original assignment and how well can you
cover it
for what values of this d and row can
you recover it
okay
okay that's good
so
you know even for this problem
it's actually quite a nice
prediction
uh
which you know this landscape was
predicted basically by techniques from
um statistical physics but
you know
sort of initi this line of work was
initiated by krakow and zebra
so they predicted this uh
way to predict the the
the hypothesized a way to predict these
transitions and if you use that for not
all equal set you get this nice picture
um so the blue region is supposed to be
easy the white region is a mixture of
where it's computationally hard or
statistically impossible
okay and in recent work we showed that
when it's conjectured to be easy this
actually
uh is an algorithm to do it
so actually specifically is the not
valid
yes it's a great question so
so you can ask the general question the
most the
the
the point is let's look at general
planted csps
i like to call them bayesian csps
because i just like the name
i made up so yeah so uh
so what what is what what's the general
model here it's a
you have a
hidden vector which takes values from
one through k and let's say the hidden
vector is sampled from a product prior
meaning each x i is sampled from
some distribution
mu
over 1 through k
and then
what you see on
this is your hidden vector and what you
see are linearly many sparse
observations
so for instance in community detection
you see edges and you see an edge you
sort of get some information of whether
the two endpoints are equal or not
or it could be not all equals at csp you
see a triple a clause and you see that
gives some information about the three
variables involved
or it could be just a single
variable maybe you get
the value of one of the variables x i or
maybe you get a value of one a variable
with some noise
so but basically
you have observations which are sparse
they depend on constant number of
variables
and there are linearly many of them the
key point is
there's order n observations
okay and these observations come from
uh
if a fixed number of types right so it
could be not all equals could be
you know edges in a community detection
or some other thing we fix a set of
types of observations that you make
and uh you get observations from that
okay i'm actually
not going to formally define this model
because you know it's just um
just a lot of notation then but but i
hope uh
you know you have a sense of what the
model is um you know if
it'll be good
so
the varying edges are sampled or the
hyperedge is a sample is just like an
error screening model so
depending on the value of x i x j x k
the sum probability
c over n squared
that you add a clause of type
uh some type between them
and you do it independently for every
triple
or every so it's so it's a general base
in csp so that's what i define
okay and for a general patient csp you
can ask whether you can recover x you
can detect it from a random instance and
so on
a hyper edge and base then based on the
projection uh based on the projection of
x uh to that hyper edge there is a
random variable y
over some set which i don't know and
it's not something
yeah and um
you know you can use this thing to model
many different things for example let's
say you're doing planted not on equal
set and then you want to say oh i
actually
learned the values of some alpha
fractional variables now what happens to
the complexity of this problem
or you could say maybe i have planted
not all equal sat and
every variable i learned its value
uh you know in a noisy way meaning i got
another zi bit for x i another big zi
which is noisy and you know
it um
tells you something about except now
this is what is the recovery threshold
what's the detection threshold so
basically it's a very general model so
only restrictions again key restrictions
to keep in mind i'm always going to be
talking about linearly many observations
so there won't be any dense graphs it
will be sparse graphs will be order in
sparse graphs and sparse psychographs
and
it's always analogous to address reading
models of graphs and hypergraphs meaning
for every triple the sum probability c
over n squared that you add a
constraint of type
some uh
uh types uh any particular type to it
and i independently do it so it's like
an add-on
okay so i'd like to show more pictures
just because uh
yeah see so the
picture on top is what you get if you
uh
look at not all equal three sat
and not on equal five set a mixture of
not only two three saturn five star
the picture on the bottom is
the predicted easy region and hard
reasons for
like a strange variant of
community detection
i think let's say there are four
communities
and you learn the
first bit of the community labels
um and then you don't know the second
bit and you ask
can you um so all these pictures the
white area is both like the impossible
you don't distinguish between them yeah
why in all this because white is both
hard and impossible and blue isn't easy
and it's always the case that there
exists that they have these has non-zero
measures
actually
no we don't know
i don't know if uh in all of this uh so
let me be actually more clear for the
audience actually so
there are two things that can happen in
the white region here one is it is
statistically impossible to recover
the other is it's computationally hard
to recover
and um
the the the theory or the that i'm going
to describe which is from
it doesn't tell you
it doesn't pertain to figuring out
uh the transition between statistically
impossible to computationally impossible
it's just the other transition the
transition to the left which is between
computationally possible
too hard or impossible
okay so it's the
computation
evidently yes yes yeah yeah so right so
that these are all hypothesized
transitions and that's in fact probably
the most exciting part of this that
yes yes yes yeah that's right so the
computational ones are all uh
hypothesized many of the statistical
ones have been of course formally proven
the the computational ones are
hypothesized and that's sort of what
makes this a really interesting
area for me in that
you have these
very very precise predictions
and you know we should either prove it
or disprove it
right so
any other questions of this
so
so okay so i guess uh i've met already
said this a little bit so the question
is why why do i why these problems what
what's special about these problems
among all the things
well i mean the reason i chose these
problems is firstly we allow csps as
theorists you know we uh
you know csps
give a very nice
benchmark to test media for algorithms
and hardness techniques so it's
analogous to um
so
if you look at combinatorial
optimization there's a whole variety of
problems in combinator optimization
but
a lot of the focus is on max cut
and whereas there's
more important problems in practice
maybe price collecting tsps or all sorts
of combinational properties problems the
reason we concentrate on max cut is
because it's simple and we can prove
things about it and maybe it helps us
make progress so in a similar way
for me two community statistical
block model or just sbms stochastic
block models and this
model of bayesian csps
is like the max cut of
statistical influence
of course there are more complicated
priors which are not independent and so
on which are important and interesting
to study but this is one way maybe maybe
we can make some initial progress
csps are great for reductions in the
reductions you know
it's a there's a whole theory of
reductions for csps which is the base of
this
dichotomy conjecture
the gadget productions
the second reason which i really like
this area of promises
is
at least for this particular class of
problems
there's a comprehensive and
unified prediction of the computational
transition in according to statistical
physics
at least for this thing
so you know
the work is cut out for us
right
if you look at different problems the
predictions are still
being made or there's no comprehensive
way to
write down for a class of problems what
is the prediction but here it's very
detailed and
comprehensive so it's a good
thing to study
and i should add that
one thing that's really
missing from what i'm going to describe
is there's almost an analogous theory
around
dense problems
like spiked wigner and over there the
discussion is centered around
approximate message passing as opposed
to belief propagation
and this
analogous theory there
and i'm not going to touch on that
because i understand the mp much less
than i understand vp which is less so we
won't talk about it but i just wanted to
point out that that's a big omission
here
but for now you know for these stocks
for the most part of these talks we'll
talk about bayesian csps
any questions
this
okay so here's my lecture plan
so
if everything goes as per plan
uh we'll do
we'll talk about
map estimates and a certain sdp
hierarchy in this lecture
in the next lecture we'll actually talk
about belief propagation we'll write
we'll talk about how how to
draw these pictures that i showed you
and tomorrow in the morning
i hope to do like a
demo theorist demo of sum of squares
sdps
and the last lecture
um i just get to vent out about all my
problems in life um
uh all the problems are playing playing
my existence so it's good okay
so
any questions
all right so just to
familiarize ourselves with this example
a little bit more
okay so just to recall this is going to
be a
mod model for a little while
so
there are two two partitions there's a
this side is labeled plus one the other
side is labeled minus one
the
edges between partitions are
sampled with d times one plus epsilon
over n
within a partition they're labeled with
probability d times one minus epsilon
epsilon over n
and uh
yeah and the goal is to recover x
partially
okay
okay so that's the problem
all right so uh sorry
that was my rehearsal sorry but
actually let me not do that let's just
continue with what i have here okay so
okay so uh
so you have a graph g
and sample from stochastic block model
what is it that we really want to do we
really want to look at the posterior
which is probability of x given g
that's what we want to care about but
result really care about
probability of x given g is proportional
to probability of x comma g
that's clear this is bayes rule
so and if i write down the probability
that x
x comma g
you know that's
this product here so
let p in
p in be the probability that i add edges
within the cluster
and p out is a probability that i add
edges out across the cluster so p out is
d over n times 1 plus epsilon
p in is d over n times 1 minus epsilon
okay
so you write down what is the
probability of x comma g
which is it's given by this
expression here
okay
and basically it is proportional to
this quantity here
and the key point i want to get to
is that you can
you can write the write down the
probability of x given g
in this form it's a boltzmann
distribution
it's e to the power minus
beta g of x it's proportional to e to
the power minus beta g of x where g of x
is essentially
the
quadratic form associated with the
adjacency matrix of the graph so it's
just x summation over i j
x i x j i j in the edges of the graph
and the normalization constant is z of g
which is the partition function
and
what is e to the minus beta e to the
minus beta is square root of
p in over p r
the exact form is not super important
but the key thing i want to drive is
that
the probability is e to the power minus
a quadratic function the quadratic
function is the summation x over i j x i
x j
edges of the graph
okay so that's uh basically the
posterior
and
if you look at a neighborhood
of of this graph
how does it look like well it looks like
an eredarine graph
because you don't see the labels
okay if you look at just a neighborhood
of a vertex in this graph it looks like
an endoscenic graph
in fact you know if you want to generate
a neighborhood of a vertex up to
distance l what you do is you start with
the vertex
you pick a poisson
random variable whose expectation is d
and you sample that many neighbors for
each of the neighbors you pick another
poisson random variable with expectation
b you pick that many neighbors and you
generate this tree
you should see a tree
and most neighborhoods are trees for for
any constant depth and that's how the
neighborhoods will look so this is how
the neighborhood of a graph of a vertex
in this these random graphs look like
and so the as you can see it looks just
like as it would in uh erdogan graph
and
if you look at not all equal three set
or there the how does the neighborhood
look like well you have vertex
you sample a poisson
random variable with an appropriate
expectation
and each of its neighbors will be
clauses
you'll have clauses um for every one of
the neighbors of this variable
so this variable will participate in
these clauses
and those clauses are because not all
equal three set they have two other
variables those will be some other
variables which are not there in the
picture
and then
they will have
poisson number of neighbors which are
clauses and so on so forth
okay so that's how the neighborhood will
look like
and
if if you saw the labeling also
if you saw the labeling of the vertices
then it looked slightly different
well how does it look well you have a
label for this vertex which is plus
you sample
um
a poisson
number of neighbors
who's with mean d minus
and you and there'll be that many minus
neighbors
and you sample another poisson random
variable with
whose mean is d plus
and there'll be that many plus neighbors
and then you continue
this vertex minus will have poisson
d d plus number of variables
with a plus and
b minus with a minus and so on so you
just grow the tree
the only difference is that once you
have the labels you have a two different
poisson random variables which add up to
the original mean and that's how the
neighborhoods look like
okay so that's labeled by mode sentries
all right so um
the you know the plus guys have a plus
ninja with high probability the nice
guys have
my favorite
probability like should i guess like i'm
i was thinking that if that was the case
the vertices here the mean minus is
basically the edges that disagree
yeah b minus is the edges that go across
and d plus the edges that stay within
the cluster and that meaning stays the
same whether you're at plus or minus so
the second layer is just
like the second layer is inverted like
yeah secondly this should be a minus
j minus and this should be a plus
okay any other questions
all right so okay so now
okay so let's get to work so okay i'm
going to talk about
map estimate what's a map estimate which
is basically you find an x that
maximizes the probability that x given g
okay it maximizes this
e to the minus beta g of x
and in particular
it just amounts to in as as i defined it
just a moment of finding the max cut in
this graph
okay it's really just finding max curt
in this graph so map estimate is just
fine max cut in the graph
okay so that's good because
um you know we know how to find max cuts
let's just try to use gomon cdm sdp
okay let's write down the government's
williamson sdp for max cut
and
try to solve it
and use the value of the government's
lens in sdp to distinguish between
a random graph and a stochastic block
model
okay and it's somewhat successful
so
you can show that the government
solution sdp
works very well
either you are either if you are very
well above the threshold
or it works as close to the case
threshold as possible if you make the
degree go to infinity
but we don't know yet
if you can use the value of the
government silence in sdp to distinguish
between
the random graphs and stochastic block
model
we don't know this
yet
[Music]
but
there's an issue with this approach
the approach is the issue is the
following
let's
throw away the government syllabus in
sdp
and let's say you computed
the maximum cut using an exponential
time algorithm
so given the graph run an exponential
time algorithm to find the maximum cut
and look at the value of the maximum cut
we don't know even if that can
distinguish between planted and random
and the reason is the
following even if you let's say you're
in the situation where you're close to
this threshold
even a random graph
with no planted communities
has a
maximum cut which is larger than the
planted cut
on the stochastic block model
okay so let me
this you know
this fact uh
took me
a few months to believe but
so let me
it's a little surprising but
so
so this is a random
graph and this is planted
okay
the planted graph there is a planted cut
right that's called the planted cut x
okay so the planted cut has a value
max cut value or the cut value
of
the planted cut on this graph
you hope that because this is a planted
cut it must have a lot of crossing edges
exactly we know its value its value is
exactly
uh d times one plus epsilon
over n or something or d times one
percent
so we know exactly the value of this and
it's a good we expect that it's a good
cut because
but what happens is in a random graph
there are all kinds of cuts
there are good cuts and
bad cuts and very good cuts the best cut
in a random graph is actually has a
value higher than the planted cut in the
stochastic block model
the best cut
in
random graph
as a has more edges crossing than the
max
than the planted cut in this graph
it took a little while for me to
internalize this so
when you're close to the case threshold
let's say you're just above the case
threshold this is the issue
so what that means is that if you just
use an algorithm which is
find the value of the best cut and you
if it's more than
the planted value then um
uh use uh
uh use that as a distinguisher it does
not work
okay that's a problem with a map
estimate in that it
will it still correlates with the
climate cut
will it yeah i don't know if it's known
that it should but we don't know i don't
know if somebody has written down the
proof that the best cut in uh
it's believable yeah on the other hand
we cannot hope to recover
cut perfectly right because it's a very
sparse small yes
so ah no no right right now but uh he's
looking at just distinguishing just for
distinguishing this for distinguishing
right yeah
sorry
just for the distinguishing problem um
the most natural thing you try is this
sort of thing and it sort of doesn't
work
so
it is believable that if you find the
best cut in the planted world it
correlates with x but uh
i mean you need to do a lot of you need
to prove it we don't know how to prove
it yet
um
and this brings back the question what
is the right sdp to do in france
is i mean we just wrote down max cut
because it was a map estimate but
it's not clear if that's the right sdp
that we should use to inference
[Music]
so
here's another sdp which i suggest
so
yes
is it do you know that it's not or i
mean is it is the value of the cut uh of
the max button and the standard higher
than random
it's believable that it should be we
don't know it's not written up like that
like maybe i mean i i don't know how to
do it but i'm sure somebody knows how to
prove it really and it's believable that
it should be true but it's quite
difficult to analyze in fact
even
yeah i mean
so
okay i might be wrong here but
but my my recollection is that uh
the actually the analyzing the value of
the government's filaments in sdp
in a random graph is easier than
analyzing the value of the true true max
cut in a random graph and even for the
government syllabus and sdp on a random
graph the montanari same work was quite
involved and they
i mean in fact the way the
monarchy saying
paper works here is that it proves that
in the planted world
the government syllabus in sdp has a
value higher than the planted solution
so in particular you solve the sdp and
optimally and the optimal solution
is not meant to be the planted cut at
all it's something even better than the
planet cut it's some cheating solution
better than the planetary but uh yeah
that's how it works so
this is some something slightly
unnatural about
uh the using this sdp
exactly the numbers the left-hand side
would be like some of the parisi
constants would be something like uh
advantage over half the left-hand side
would be something like i don't know
0.67 over square root d or something
like that and then in the right hand
side i guess it will be 0.5 over square
d when you're close to right right yeah
yeah yeah so the value is well i think
the value of the max cut is known for
by
demo
but but yeah but you know all of these
are very hard
um so okay so we want to write an sdp
and so what are the two criteria that i
have in mind tonight firstly the sdp
should help me distinguish a random
graph from an uh from a planted graph if
i run it it should be feasible in one in
feasible in the other the second most
important criteria that i have is that
the thing that i'm looking for should be
a solution for this we're used to having
is writing sdp relaxation so
the thing that i'm looking for the max
cut is a solution to the max cutting
relaxation so i want that the planted
cut
should satisfy the constraints of my smp
right so
the planted cut should be the solution
to my sleeping and it should be able to
distinguish planted from random
so what's the idea the idea is very
natural
so
what is it well firstly the key point is
that if i look at statistics local
statistics
uh in the in a planted graph they all
concentrate
for example the number of edges that
cross
from left to right
is some d times one plus epsilon over n
plus or minus order square root n
there's only like a root and deviation
on that
for example if i ask for what is the
number of parts that
go from
let's say
left to left to right
number of parts of length two that do
this
okay that's some number with the order
root and deviation
and same thing holds for all kinds of
part any any kind of statistic that you
ask for they concentrate if you ask for
how many
trees do i have that look like this in
the graph
well that's going to be some constant
times n plus root n
okay so that's good so
in some sense
for any acyclic graph the the number of
copies of that concentrate
so the
very simple idea is we write an sdp
which says the following
which basically says find me a
assignment x
such that
for every labeled
structure with d labeled vertices and
capital d unlabeled vertices
okay so let's say
little d is two
and capital d is five that means that if
you look at any structure with
five vertices
with two
labeled ones
right
i want the number of copies of
this such a thing in my sdp solution
should be the same as what i expect
okay it's just going one step beyond
saying i want this many cottages
it's just saying all kinds of structure
this is inspired by this
influential work by barack and all on
sudha calibration
but
it's a very simple yes so now we have a
hierarchy depending on what size
structures on which i impose this
constraint i have a hierarchy of these
things
and
i might finish a little earlier but
um but basically
the
the point is that
every local statistics is a constant
degree polynomial
in x
so for example if i want
if i want to know
how many copies of this
are there in my
in my graph
well it's just
some let me call this 3t
somewhere all copies of p in my graph
and i want the left vertex
to be
i want the left vertex to be plus and
the right vertex to be minus
so it is
1 plus x u
by 2 times 1 minus
x z by 2
sum over all copies
u v w z
okay if you have two labeled vertices
it's a degree two polynomial in x if you
have little d labeled what if it's a
little
degree polynomial in x
and so if it's degree two we already
know how to write it is in terms of sdp
because you know it's just
you know if you want to write this in
terms of an sdp it's just
one plus
um
yeah you can write it in terms of
vectors just like governments williamson
so
we'll see more about the relation
between polynomials and
vectors and so on tomorrow we'll do sum
of squares sdp
but
this
is a family of constraints that we can
add in sdp okay and it's a hierarchy of
family of constraints
well right now
it is for distinguishing but you know
it's an sdp that you can write and you
can hope that
you can use the solution to recover too
but
okay and what do we know about this
well we showed that
if you look at this hierarchy
it's called a local statistic
hierarchy it has two parameters two nd
as you increase capital d
you can do recovery as close to the case
threshold as you want
okay
and
the key parameter of course here is the
two which means you only have a degree
two polynomials there which means this
is almost like governments williamson
they only have vectors you don't have a
sum of squares sdp hierarchy so you can
still call solve it in quadratic time or
maybe even near linear time
but
it has a property that
as you increase this capital d
you
you can solve detection as close to the
case threshold as you want
okay
and one nice thing about solving using
sdps is that you get robustness for free
so
what is robustness imagine i
took a stochastic block model i changed
epsilon and vertices edges in the graph
arbitrarily like a little oven edges in
the graph
well why is an sdp thing
robust
well basically if i change only little
off and edges in the graph
you can more or less say that
the sub graph counts of length t
right if you look at parts of length t
i still where t is a constant let's say
p is hundred parts of length hundred i
change it by little of n
okay
so all the sub graph counts stay the
same so if a feasible solution to the
original sdp
stays a feasible solution to the newest
visualization original graph stays
feasible even
after you modify the graph
so it works um it sort of distinguishes
between
um
stochastic block models with adversarial
noise on epsilon images
and
true
random graph
yes
a bit confused why isn't it
into the d you're just constructing this
thing and read a number of steps
right so the thing is that since we're
dealing with a sparse graph if i look at
a structure with d edges there are only
linearly many such structures
because uh
um
right but actually you know
connected structures
connect connected structures
okay and you can find them
yeah yeah it's just
like m times d to the t you know like
the degree to the
little d to the power d to the cap
there's a
what's the number of neighborhoods okay
yeah and and uh actually you know
really the proof uh you know look i'd
like to talk about this in terms of
specific hierarchy but it's kind of
systematic but really the proof only
uses uh
parts of non-backtracking walks of
length t
the only statistic that you really need
is really non-backtracking walks of
length t so really just parts of length
p
um it sort of makes sense because
locally all the neighborhood is every
neighborhood is a tree
right and so if you're only two labeled
vertices plus and minus
somewhere in the tree so the rest of the
dangling edges are sort of useless
more or less and
um
okay so
uh i'm thinking that yeah capital d is
like a constant
or the little d is two yeah with here
it's little d one two um yeah so in fact
it turns out the two is enough
um
or the or the or the degree or the
degree of the graph is a constant yeah
the degree of
different
oh yes yes there are two sorry yeah
there's two different little d's yes so
sorry there's a graph degree is little d
and local statistic little d was the
degree in x
but yeah
yeah
okay
any questions
all right so um
all right so we might actually end up
stopping early but uh it's fine
just don't want to start the next topic
in the middle of a lecture but okay but
before we stop uh i wanted to list a
couple of problems that
are interesting
so one of them
is this thing called verification
it's sort of a silly problem but
so okay firstly we want to prove that
this
community detection eventually want to
do these assertions and prove that
community detection is actually
computationally hard
in this region between customs threshold
and there and this
so there's a region where we want to
prove that the problem is
computationally hard meaning no
efficient algorithm can solve this
detection problem
uh but
like where does it go stay where does
this problem stay is it an np problem or
is it like where is it we don't we don't
have a good idea of this
so here's a verification problem
so you have a stochastic block model
and
somebody gives you the graph and the
communities
okay so you're given the graph and the
communities
and what you all you need to do is to
verify that the graph g is generated by
the communities
it's an np problem
so what is the np guarantee
well
if the graph is sampled from
g if the graph and the samp
is is a stochastic block model
then output yes
but the key point is if i take an
errados line graph
i take a you know just a random graph
then
they should not exist any choice of
communities for which your output s
right so for all
assignments x
if i give you
if if it given adults any random graph
and x you should output no
okay
so it's really the verification problem
if i give the graph and the communities
can you verify
that
can verify that g is
a stochastic block model
and of course for two communities
i think this is easy because
well there's nothing interesting going
on here because
um
well the problem was impossible to solve
up to a point
and then we have an efficient algorithm
to solve so there's no region where
you know something interesting is going
on
but if you look at k communities
uh
then it's more interesting
so in particular one thing that i should
say is that
um the canonical algorithm
that we have in mind doesn't work
the canonical algorithm that we have in
mind is oh just
test if your cut has that many crossing
edges
like you expect p times one perception
and crossing edges p minus one
measurement crossing and non crossing
edges you just test that that doesn't
work because of the max cut reasoning
right i guess
the quantifier is really like
the problem is when x depends on g right
yes yes yeah yeah
the problem is
right
yeah exactly
if somebody takes a random graph and
tries to convince you that it's a
congenital you should be able to
distinguish that
okay and now
so
local sales are hierarchy works right so
it works for above the case threshold i
guess my real question is let's say you
do the planted k coloring or the k
community model and you're just below
the case threshold
just below the threshold where we know
any polytime algorithms we don't know
any poly time algorithm here
for detection because it's just below
threshold in fact the problem is
supposed to be hard
but now if i tell you the communities
you should at least be able to verify it
otherwise
it's a little bit uh
unsatisfactory to me to talk about a
problem that's hard
when you can't even recognize the
solution
somehow it's a like you should be able
to at least recognize something if i
showed you the solution because that's
what you're trying to find
right so
it becomes harder to
yeah
can i give you
some extra information like for example
if you give me
you verify not just based on the
communities but baseball communities and
the max part related to them
right because we expect the next part to
not follow exactly communities
i think some such approach should work
in fact
yeah i don't know i mean look like even
local statistics might work um
yeah i don't know actually like even
local statistics one should expect works
but i don't know how to prove it
suppose you can't verify just based on
giving the correct predictions but we
can verify
if
i get the correct uh communities and the
max cut associated with it like the
the random
variation
yes yes ah yes
right right okay so i guess that that
belong corresponds to another thing
which is okay the verification problem
something there's another more general
thing is can even certify can somebody
show you some certificate that helps and
yes the max cut can help yeah i think if
you showed them sure yeah if you yeah
but basically yeah it's
yeah
i don't know if uh
i mean
i think it's a workable problem but it's
i don't know if a solution to it yeah
yeah
becomes easier if we allow like the
witness or the the partitions to be
slightly correlated and not just the
exactly correct ones yeah i think
yeah i think if you
allow for general witnesses there should
be a witness yeah i think it's a yeah
it should let me yeah
i expect there to be a solution to this
yeah
but i just uh
yeah it's a good question to think about
it okay it's a little bit silly okay so
but it's a good thing
i mean it's a little bit silly in
practice but
it's actually maybe it's not silly in
fact if somebody shows you the community
if you have to say okay it's good for me
or bad for me otherwise what's the point
of finding communities
like statistical significance or
something like that
yeah the hypothesis of the community was
generated based on the data right right
yeah yeah exactly
yeah
okay so this is one open problem
uh
as i said i told you i'm going to went
about my problems in life so here's
another one um
this one is a
simple so it's a sort of unrelated to
what i've been talking about but
is vaguely related um so
here's a look at the following sampling
problem
so the input is n i just give you n
and i give you a clause density alpha
which is some constant let's say 2.4 or
something okay
and what i want you to do
is to sample a random three set formula
with alpha and clauses
and an assignment around your uniformly
random assignment to that formula
okay so i'm not giving you the formula
nor the
nothing i'm just giving you a number n i
say n is thousand
give me a random formula with thousand
variables
and this many clauses
and along with it a random assignment to
that a uniformly random assignment to
that
okay so
it's a joint sampling question and you
can ask this for any csp or you can even
ask for planted problems for planted
problems
you have to be a little bit more careful
here to say give me a stochastic block
model
graph
and give me two choices of communities
because one choice of community is easy
because i can sample x and sample g
given x
in the planted world but if if i ask you
give me g and x and y sample from the
posterior that's already a hard problem
and so this should be
like this should be an
intuitively an easy problem because the
only input i've given you is n
right it can't be sharply hard or np
hard or anything like it's just i'm just
giving you a number and thousand
right click you know give me a random
thing like that
should be hard
yeah uh
yeah it's i think you could but i guess
the key point is um yeah like
like you can ask this sort of a joint
sampling question for any of the models
in fact random three set will be like
the amazing thing but any of these
models and so why is this interesting
well it's interesting in practice for
the following reason i think
um so
statistical physics wise let's say
there's a conjecture
saying
let's say the overlap gap is
there at 2.4 at alpha equal to 2.4 uh
two random solutions have an overlap of
0.7 there's some statistical physics
conjecture if you want to experimentally
verify this
what you need to do you need to sample a
three-sided formula and sample two
random assignments to it and check their
overlap
right and you don't care which formula
nobody gives you you want the formula
and the assignments together so if you
want to experimentally verify
statistical physics predictions
this is really the problem that you want
to solve
so it is like a very basic problem you
should do it
with the natural planting just
for some three exer i don't know
maybe it shouldn't be true i mean for 3x
i think we should be able to wait
for the subspace right so it should be
yeah yeah
yeah i think you know yeah i think for
three extra you know we should be able
to do everything that we want to do but
uh yeah but i guess in general even
i guess my point is that all the random
block literature and everything
you fix the three set formula first
and then you do try to sample it and of
course it's a hard and important problem
but here i'm not even fixing the
formulas if you could somehow sample the
formula and the assignment together by
some random walk or something i don't
know it'll be amazing and the reason i
think it's really amazing even from a
theoretical point of view
is that
so
so if you know like a traditional
statistical physics way of understanding
the solution space
is to say
okay at alpha equal to 2.4 the solution
space shatters and you prove the value
of alpha is equal to 2.4 using some
bp prediction or something very
complicated
right
and you have the exact formula right
your exact formula for at the right the
position of the threshold
a cs way of saying that we understand
the solution space
is that where
we have an algorithm
to
tell you the value of alpha
right or right and this is like the like
a cs way of understanding solution space
is to be able to do this in like in
particular
um somehow if you have an algorithm that
solves this problem that algorithm knows
at what point
the solution space shatters or anything
like that
right so so the joint sampling question
is as
a cs way of approaching these uh
threshold questions
but i think it's just an interesting
question you want just to run run it and
practice because you want to verify
conjecture you want to run this
okay
and
okay and so i get paid
oh yes
all
right
why do you want threesat in particular
as opposed to some other like case ad
anything yeah
yeah mostly a set is an example here um
any like the this the class of joint
sampling questions is interesting i
think they should be easier than just 3d
sampling and i think they're interesting
for me um
which is an impressive question and i
mean i think for three seconds on it
like this problem should be hard because
implicitly you have to understand the
solution space if you have to have such
an algorithm like for example you have a
single algorithm that works for all n
already you're proving that
you know the limit exists as n goes to
infinity implicitly because you have a
single algorithm that works for all n as
opposed to even and the threshold is
something odd and the threshold is
something so it's it's tricky so
um
but yeah so you know i get paid to think
about these questions a lot like i get
paid a lot to think about these
questions i guess
so i thought you know
a more economical thing to try is to um
um offer
some of that money to you
so
so i'll
promise to pay a hundred dollars
for anyone solving this question over
the semester
all right so i think i'll
stop here before we get on to the next
topic
[Applause]
so for clarification and your
verification problem if uh i gave you a
and b the information theoretics special
um
i think so yes because the knowledge of
a and b should not change the yeah it's
a subtle proof but
yeah
i think i think that's true the
information there isn't sure
if i guess information theoretically you
could enumerate maybe over uh
all the potential candidates and what
discipleship so you could distinguish
if you had a verification maybe yeah
yeah but i think there's some chapters
here
subset on which the the true parameter
is sparse like this
slightly faster than if you don't know
this unknown
[Music]
yeah i think uh
you know um
so yeah so this is a
so you know a couple of semesters about
the assignments program
and
and there were some
initial discussions on the topic and
somebody gave a formal proof that
indeed information theory
doesn't show it's little bit subtle but
it's i think it was short but subtlety
there's some subtlety there yeah
okay so let's plan to meet back here in
one minute